au début du confinement on a tous fait
les réserves que l'on a mise au frais
mais d'après plusieurs jours dans le
réfrigérateur
les bananes sont devenus tout loire en
façade seule la couleur de la banane est
dû à des substances qu on appelle les
phénols la banane est un fruit tropical
qui une fois qu'il a commencé à mûrir ne
supporte pas le froid en dessous de 10
12 degrés les cellules qui composent la
peau se dégradent la peau se ramollit
les cellules sont moins étanches des
substances jusque là séparés se
combinent c'est le cas de l'oxygène
contenu dans l'air une enzyme et les
fameux phénol à nouveau composer
appareil qui ressemble à la mélanine
vous savez ces petits grains qui font
brunir la peau quand on prend le soleil
la banane bronze pour se protéger à
l'intérieur la chair qui contient
beaucoup moins de phénol reste blanche
est parfaitement digeste
comme cette capsule de des conflits
n'est allé à demain et n'oubliez pas
pour les confiner mais en restant lien
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus gens
réalisent une nouvelle chaque jour alors
pour ne rater aucune de ces capsules 2d
confiné abonnez-vous et activer la
petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain